so what do you want to do tonight like i
was thinking maybe we could meet up with
amy and brad and like before that we
could go to angelo's and before that we
could like just go
vegan i have something to say
oh i had to say it in person because
it's
it's like super important
okay um
i know this is sudden but look i've been
thinking about this for a while
and i know this is something that needs
to happen
i'm breaking up with you cool love it
totally fine
with that
really yeah cause i thought
i was i was really worried that you were
gonna be like mad matt
oh my god are you kidding me no of
course i'm not mad
people grow apart it happens it's like
part of life no i'm totally fine like
love it love it love it
um so
uh um you know we we had a good run
don't be a stranger yeah can i just
can i ask why why
yeah like what i was like i'm doing some
work on myself and like trying to grow
as a person so
i really like appreciate to know why
yeah um
okay yeah that's like you know i think
that you're kind of like
a controlling person thank you
thank you for that that's nice thank you
for that
cool no problem yeah so you know what
your problem is andre
what you keep tabs on people
every little thing somebody does you
have to keep a tab of it
wait i i i can't tell if you're angry or
not i'm not
i'm totally not angry oh no i'm excited
it's good it's just like
you said your piece and i just think
that
i deserve the human decency to save my
peace
right right is that is that not okay
no no no it's no of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says it
really i i i don't think that i am yes
you are
andre yes
[Music]
okay now like you sound pretty i'm not
angry
i'm not angry i'm fine i love it
i love that you came to my house and you
broke up with me
in my space and i'm gonna think about
that every time i'm here that's great
that is so perfect for me it's the best
thing
around here where else was i supposed to
do it because you won't come to my house
oh
here he is the puppet master is back but
i'm not no i'm not the puppeteer
you're doing this to me it's true you
won't come to my house so my apartment
looks like two rats just
in it every day oh right like thank you
for that
i'm a [ __ ] thank you i didn't no i
didn't say [ __ ] i didn't always say
am i evil or am i in bed no no you're
not evil vegan
why are you punishing me i know i'm not
punishing you i know you broke up with
me and i'm not supposed to feel punished
i see who thinks like that
i don't know i can't i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay me again i
i guess i didn't think it through well
it's like too late now i mean we're
dying no it's not too late
megan megan seriously i just i i i i had
a feeling
that i thought was true and clearly
clearly it wasn't true
i'm so confused like are you breaking up
with me are you not bringing up with me
megan i'm not breaking up with you okay
cool so what do you want to do tonight
like i want to hang out with amy and
brad but maybe before that we can go to
angelo's
what just happened
you